thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh Philip Trowbridge is away
from Des today so he asked me to report
on HB 1312. Mr Pelletier is with us in
between us and others in the room we
should be able to answer any questions
so as most of you know over the summer
an ad hoc committee was formed that met
in person twice and was significant and
I mean a lot of additional
Communications and reviews between the
parties we generated the report that
you've seen the committee consisted of
Representatives of nhdes the bcrb DHHS
the State Fire Marshal's office and the
New Hampshire building officials
Association and we appreciate the input
from representative Schmidt and McGuire
who attended some of the meetings
uh you'll recall that in addressing
questions as to the required size of
grease interceptors HB 1312 also
resulted in a conflict with RSA 155a to
X which prohibits state agencies from
amending the building code so we tried
to deal with both of those issues the
factual basis and a summary of the
conflicts the the issues that that come
up on the table are laid out in the
report I'll summarize the action steps
that came out of the exercise here which
are we get into in more detail in the
report so there are nine steps that we
all agreed on one would be to to amend
the international plumbing code our
plumbing code definition of building
sewer such that the IPC would not
regulate piping and equipment from just
outside the building to the septic or
sewer system as discussions have gone on
that may be narrowly tailored down to
deal just with septic which is what DEA
yes regulates
that would leave Des regulating what we
call the building sewer the pipe from
the building to the septic tank
and Municipal agencies
regulating their own systems
as we get into the wording that has
tentacles that go to unforeseen
locations so that will get worked out
but in terms of the interaction between
the code and Des
we've basically taken the code or
proposed to take the code out of that
element for septic tank pipes and leave
primarily but not only because half the
towns in the state have no building
inspector so nobody thinks that Des
shouldn't be looking at this stuff
we would also amend the IPC such that if
an interior or hydromechanical separator
is the only separator provided Des
approval would be required in addition
to the plumbing code
we'd address the IPC to address a
technical issue with drainage from
certain restaurant sinks when
hydromechanical interceptors are used
that just gets into when you need an
indirect train and a direct train and it
was sort of a sub issue that came out of
all of this
Des would amend their rules to
explicitly permit interior Hydro
mechanical separators for certain small
occupancies and the listing of the
conditions for that are in the report
these are occupancies where currently
this approach is normally permitted by
waiver they would write that into the
rule so it would be permitted by right
Des would also amend their rules to more
explicitly address Greece interceptors
in the waiver program so you don't have
to sort of know what's going on before
you get into this they would also amend
their rules to permit a minimum 500
gallon size for exterior gravity type
interceptors but retain the current
36-hour detention time
that argument and the defense of that is
in the report and I believe that the
folks with us today can get into it in
more detail if if needed
Des will review various reference
standards in their rules and in the IPC
so there are standards written by others
on how to build a gravity tank a
reference different standards and try
and bring those together so we would
either amend one set of rules or the
other so that they would both say the
same thing ideally
um
nhdes that building officials
Association and the mechanical licensing
board will work together to improve
training and education on all this stuff
so when this hits the road out in the
field people read the same language come
up with different opinions and through
the training and education try and get a
more standardized approach to what's
going on and then obviously both the Des
rules and the bcrb through the
ratification process need to go through
the standard channels to uh to update
things
the result of this exercise is to
eliminate the conflict between the
various regulations and to provide
changes to Des rules that will benefit
certain small users based on the
proposed action steps we do not believe
that legislative action is required but
that we can handle it through the the
bcrb Amendments and the nhdes rule
process
I would be happy to answer questions I
can answer or turn it over to Des for
anything on their side
at all
first I'd like to thank you and
everybody else who was involved in this
effort
for what you've done I think
at least I believe that this is you know
going to be a
it will eliminate some confusion and
provide flexibility for small businesses
which is good does anybody have
questions
okay
thank you very much uh and I'm
personally very grateful to the people
involved and many of whom are here today
for the very hard work that it was put
in by all of you uh and this in this
working group representative Aaron I I
don't know whether you were aware of the
fact that this was happening at the time
you weren't able to make uh either uh
the two meetings but I can assure you
having participated in both of them
um that that there was a very
significant amount of of expertise
involved and experience on the part of
the people who were there and we kicked
around a lot of stuff I recall Mr
Ted Evans who was there I think he was
the one that said you know we've never
had a meeting like this before
and I think that the fact that this
group did come together is Indica of the
not only the willingness to address the
situation but the recognition on the
part of the parties involved that that
this is a real issue and the fact that
uh that you're one of your conclusions
Mr Sherman is that legislation will not
be required but my question and my first
question would be
um is this going to uh the various
different concepts and adjustments that
you've just addressed at least briefly
in your opening remarks
whether this has uh developed a maturity
if you will that is sufficient so that
the various different state agencies and
uh and non-state agency actors uh are
already proceeding to create the
necessary the interaction of steps that
need to be made in order that you spoke
of training and so forth so is this all
currently happening is it going to have
to be triggered by something how are we
going to proceed so that that we both
incorporate the recognitions that grew
out of this working group but also
address the situation
that you also referenced into your
remarks namely that many of the entities
small towns do not have the necessary
authorities in place to make sure that
businesses such as the one that
triggered representative Aaron's
um bill that they are sufficiently
informed so we don't have this kind of a
situation proceeding further uh I know
that's a very broad question but please
approach it and address it as you will
I think perhaps des and nhpoa could
could respond to the training and
education function better than I we have
no no statutory involvement in that
ourselves
and answer your question all of this is
where we are today everybody's coming up
for air after the summer of course uh so
I suspect that much of this would be uh
proceeding in the next few months
um and the rule making and the amendment
process takes x amount of time there's
no question about that so I I don't know
if Bill or or Randy you have anything to
if I may Mr chairman well Mr Pelletier
is coming up uh I spoke with Ted deers
of
uh I'm not sure whether he's with Des or
HHS but I spoke with him yesterday and
he said that there had been further many
further discussions resulting from the
working group which Mr Sherman was
president Mr McKinney the fire marshal
Mitchell was there uh and
um other other parties it was already an
excellent group of knowledgeable people
so where where are we rainy with the
situation yeah for the record rainy
Pelletier I'm the director of The Water
Division at DES and representative
Schmidt Ted Diaz is the assistant
director of The Water Division so we're
all in Phil
we all work together as a group but I
think our initial intent is we do have
rule waiver capability but I think the
the hand the task at hand is the
educational process it's where
initially we're going to put a fact
sheet out we have it if you've ever been
on the Des website you'll see that for a
Litany of issues we have fact sheets to
kind of help people uh understand
whatever the topic may be whether it's
water quality whether it's something in
drinking water or whatever but uh intent
is is to do a fact sheet on Greece to
try and explain the issues we work hand
in hand with HH and S the food licensing
program I would certainly share that
fact sheet with them as well
and I I think now that we've kind of as
a group
um which I did not participate in but
Phil Trowbridge as you know did he's the
land resource manager at DES
and I think we're all on the same page I
think in the early goings until as you
know representative Schmidt takes
uh
six to seven eight months maybe to get a
rule making pack package done and
through j.oka but I think in the interim
we do have the ability to waive the tank
issue
um and as you know I think it's
a process of educating our staff so when
our inspectors go out we're not having
the issue that happened in in Goshen so
I think we've got a good handle on it I
think everybody's on the same page
and I see it
moving forward I think relatively
smoothly and I think if we get a problem
where there's uh negative interaction
which I I can assure you I will make
sure our staff are all educated on where
we're going with this
um so I don't see that as a problem but
I think we we're wide open to getting
people through the process and the
interim and then have it very definitive
in our rules package so someone can pick
up the document understand when a wave
is available how you get a waiver and
move forward so I think we've come to a
good conclusion and and I I don't think
the situation that arose that
representative Aaron brought to our
attention will happen again
um I just I think
we've all educated ourselves so I think
there should be a not an issue thank you
um when the fact sheet comes out could
you please send it to the committee I
I'm the chair of course we'll
distributed well I was saying the whole
Edna committee is probably the easiest
thing to do and everybody will get one
um representative fellows
thank you
um I I could be wrong and representative
Aaron can correct me if I'm wrong but
when we first had the hearing public
hearing about this bill
my understanding was what triggered the
the requirement for the grease trap was
not ice cream it was had to do with the
fryers fryers were added so but
um as we went through the discussion we
kind of came to the conclusion that
really the ice cream hard ice cream was
more of an issue than the fryers
so
um
my question is when this establishment
first got approval from HHS
that nobody questioned the hard ice
cream
so my question is
um in terms of grandfathering if there
are other establishments out there that
have had the hard ice cream all along
are these rules these rules will will
put them out of compliance possibly but
will they be grandfathered is that a
standard process or do you need to
identify that well I think what we would
make an attempt to do is considering
where we've all come through an
agreement to entertain the concept of
hydro mechanical in the building
treatment which are not big ticket items
like a thousand gallon tank or a 500
gallon tank but at the end of the day
when you think about an establishment
that's getting rid of its Wastewater on
site vis-a-vis septic system then in
fact they put their self at risk so
number one I would hope we would do a
good job of educating them about the
ramifications of not handling that
wasteload and number two they'd have the
ability to purchase an in-house
track so I think the grandfather in
question that you ask I think once these
people get an opportunity to be educated
about the risk associated you know
nowadays we're seeing especially since
the pandemic that the average septic
system depending on the side it's twenty
thousand dollars
you know so if people get in a situation
where the system fails it's going to be
a lot more cost effective to spend 500
or whatever on a grease trap so our
first attempt would be to try and
educate and not regulate
um I think at DES we try and do that in
all venues and all media that we deal
with
so I I don't think grandfathering makes
a lot of sense just because of the end
result that could happen but I'm not
sure that there's a lot of the
situations that you're talking about in
every situation is different so I think
they were first we'd start with having
an open conversation about you know
how you doing what are you doing
um but it it may very well be once we
make them aware of the risk that we may
in fact grandfather depending on the
facility
you know the type of use but I think it
it benefits everyone to be educated on
what the ramifications are of what kind
of Wastewater they're discharging if
they obviously have an on-site septic
system and and then see how that
dialogue goes okay thank you
so I I understand and I agree that in
principle it's much better to try to
educate them and and to try to have them
make a modification that wouldn't be
terribly expensive but isn't it I know
that just septic tanks
that are in place I I know about homes I
don't really know about businesses but
you get grandfathered so you know my
septic tank was put in like 40 years ago
and for a house and it would if you were
building the same house today they'd
tell me to get a bigger one yep
um
I just
am concerned that
there could be people out there and I
don't want them they didn't do anything
wrong when they set it up
that they wouldn't they wouldn't get a
fine or or being told they couldn't
operate
because of the changes we're making here
today right and I think first and
foremost assuming that they have a
state-approved septic system and they
came in
unlike the situation we dealt with that
representative Barron was dealing with
if they came in to us we'd granted a
construction approval to install a
septic system for an ice cream shack 10
years ago or 12 years ago that's a legal
system
so what we would do is we would try and
educate them and say the benefits but I
don't think we would be in there with
blazing guns saying you got to put a
grease trap in we've already approved it
so I wouldn't consider that a
grandfathering I would consider it a
state approved septic system for a
particular wastelode discharge and if
that permit that we approved was for an
ice cream stand and they're legal so
um if I could ask a question that might
clarify this so correct me if I'm wrong
but my understanding is there's nothing
in the proposed rule changes
that would be more restrictive than what
exists today
is that correct no what it does is it
opens up more options of what's
available so if something is legal and
was granted a permit today nothing in
this would revoke that nope okay thank
you
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you for your question
because the one thing that I I think we
all would be concerned about is if we
say well the this educational process
that you're both speaking about
um and I imagine that you're in the
process or will shortly be in the
process of generating some bulletins and
uh and other educational materials for
your inspectors and for the general
public for contractors plumbers and so
forth so the word will go out you know
as it has in human history with things
like washing hands before operating on
um you know people
I could go on for hours about that topic
but the thing is that we do we don't
want to
step aside from from legislative steps
as you're recommending without some firm
understanding that the Departments the
agencies and so forth are going to be
following up very quickly and that there
will be something that will cross our
desks
in the fullness of time hopefully not
long time
that will make sure that we that we're
getting this done
because I'm wondering the the the people
that triggered
um representative Aaron's bill
um they wound up having to bite the
bullet on a ten thousand on a thousand
gallon uh grease trap
uh now they're well protected in the
future and almost no matter what they do
but how many other businesses are
protect potentially in Jeopardy of
having
this kind of
um
it was not overreach it was a
misunderstanding I think of you know
what all the aspects were
given the discussion that this working
group had a lot of
you know you can't get here there from
here
uh and the net effect was that this
particular business and potentially
other businesses are also in Jeopardy of
being misinformed or maybe uh having to
Pony up a lot more money than they they
should have so what what can what can we
hear here uh to make sure that this is
going forward well I think the
difference situation is when I was asked
the earlier question about the
grandfathering issue assuming that
whatever the facility is has a state
approved septic system for that use then
they're legal in perpetuity much like uh
you probably got a 750 gallon tank today
we require 1250s we don't go into houses
and say you got to rip your tank out and
put in a new one but if you came in
because your system failed then under
the new design criteria you'd be
required to use a 1250. but prior to
that illegal because you've got a
construction approval from us the
situation that raised this issue with
representative Aaron was quite different
they originally had an approval for an
ice cream check and there was a
significant change of use the difference
today though or in the future would be
there would this be this opportunity for
an Institute grease trap depending it
met the criteria for what you were going
to do with your waist charge and if you
look at the report there's three or four
issues that would give you availability
to that wave of situation so I think
that an issue in this particular case
they probably may not have needed a
thousand gallon tank so I think because
of the progress made by the committee
that type of scenario I would not
Envision happening again and I think
that would be addressed because of the
conclusions that were arrived at in this
ad hoc committee so I think now we're
all on the same page so the issue is the
education part is the big part is
everything we do at DES and we strive
very hard to make that open
communication so we truly
philosophically would rather educate
than regulate I mean that is our
ultimate goal as an agency philosophy it
always has been as you know I've been
there my whole career and we try to work
very hard to get out of the regulatory
scheme if we can educate first so we're
not at odds with anyone so long and
short to that question is I don't
anticipate that what happened with
representative Aaron's issue would
happen again I think just because of the
conclusions of the report in the ad hoc
committee that would not happen you know
and I think the good thing about what
came out of the committee was there's
going to be very definitive
items that rule you into the waiver
process so this is how you get it so
it's not done in a dark room how do we
figure out what the waiver is uh they'll
be the criteria listed be very clear my
staff has already been educated on this
um and so it won't be what do I do how
do I get a wave oh what makes me
eligible for a waiver so I think just in
three months we've come a long way in
trying to address the situation that
happened yeah I appreciate that and I
mean they've committed to doing certain
rulemaking it's in this report I expect
that to happen and and to your concern I
mean ultimately for whatever reason it
doesn't happen there's always the option
for legislation in the future which
hopefully we can avoid
um what I'm
hoping to do is at some point we'll have
a motion to recommend not recommend for
future legislation
and when I write the report or whoever
write support we can summarize you know
what's going on here so I'd like to ask
people on the committee or anybody else
here
do you have
any any concerns that would about doing
that and if so you know do you have any
questions about
um this report or anything else that
would stand in the way of supporting a
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman I I agree with
everything you said the the only comment
I would like to make is that you know
represent representative Aaron obviously
brought this forward for a reason and is
as long as she is comfortable with
everything that we're hearing and um if
there's anything that she
that she would like to be either either
done
with either not recommending or
recommending that would be
um what I would support is you know
basically whatever she says I think um
representative Aaron could you repeat
the comments you made
separately both about your views on this
and also the views of the business
thank you so much and
I really appreciate all the work that
this committee and subcommittee and uh
you in DEA des and
hboa and bcrb have done to address this
issue and come up with a solution for it
I am internally grateful
I have spoken to my constituent about
this uh shared with him this report he
was more than pleased about
um
what was developed by this ad hoc
committee so I want to thank you and I
do have one or two questions though
um for the item number three where
you're amending the Des rules
um I'm assuming those are all ands
instead of ores that every Everything a
b c and d and e and f all of those
conditions have to be met there's it's
not an it's an and
you know it's an and okay also when you
speak about Item B that there's no deep
fryer will there be some kind of
distinguishing factor between deep
fryers that are con self-contained where
Greece is trapped within them and can be
disposed in a recycling way versus ones
that are not
yes
oh good to go yes yeah yeah no I would
think that the key is is if there's
something self-contained that can be
disposed of which is what item three in
the report talks about you have the
availability to have that in set to a
grease strap but it's the ones that you
get out and many of the restaurant
facilities we have don't have that
luxury and the grease goes somewhere
right so it's going to be a situation
and I think that
to add Clarity because you even raised
that question that would be something
that we'd want to put in the rule okay
and how how soon are the rules adopted
you said between six and eight months no
it takes that long and can't I'm going
to be candid with you I have a terrible
issue with Staffing you know and
subsurface I'm down five people we can't
attract anybody the outside economy is
paying far more than the state salaries
are paying so I will give it my best
attempt to try and get six or eight
months to get rules done on a good day
rulemaking is a six-month process by the
time you have public hearings you have
public input you get the rules drafted
you got to go to jail Caso at the very
minimum it would be at least a six-month
window but I think in the interim
because of the mentality and the
education that we've done in-house I
don't see that if it takes eight months
or no months I don't think the situation
that happened would happen because we
have all been educated on with the way
we're going to handle this stuff and
like I did say if I'm sitting here
telling you we're going to do rules
we're going to do rules right okay so
I'm assuming that prior to any rule
change these this this policy is going
to be in effect yep okay great and one
other thing on on that question on the
prior part of it and again correct me if
I'm wrong but I think the business like
the one that raised this issue would
need a waiver but in number four part a
Roman one and two
it gets into
um you know if they're do if they're
putting minimal grease down the system
then they could get the waiver and not
be required uh the tank that you know
external tank well so then Mr chair with
that being said I am certainly
um
very happy with the result of this and I
would concur with the committee uh
recommending no further legislative
action in in lieu of these rules being
adopted and uh in the interim being
adopted as well thank you any other
um I had that same question but my other
question would be does it make sense for
us to kind of put in a pla recommend a
placeholder bill
um because of the fact that
that
um that there could be modifications to
the two to the plumbing code and well I
given the schedule and the legislative
schedule and that you know if we were to
put in an LSR now
it would have to have public hearings
sometime before they'd be able to do
rulemaking so I don't see that as useful
I mean if you're concerned that
something happens and the rulemaking
doesn't happen
you wouldn't know until after our
legislative next year and that would
have to happen the following year
right so I don't think that would work
and I can assure you I sit here and I
tell you we're going to do rules we are
going to do it I'm not disbelieving you
placeholder bills are really uh they
they don't accept placeholder bills
anymore you have to have a real bill
right and so it would have to it would
have to go you know we would end up
hearing it before the full committee and
we'd probably have to itl it because
things would be in an unknown state so
that wouldn't make any sense any other
questions
we're good
any further questions
um would somebody like to make a motion
or I can
I'll tell you I'll do it I know you're
not
silent
oh certainly
um so
um I move that uh that we uh that this
not rec we not recommend for future
legislation
and um
so a second a second oh well that okay
either one I second that motion okay
that's fine and so um we'll take a vote
I vote uh well actually I'm last so
representative fellows
um yes and representative Rhodes yes
and uh terrebotes yes so that's what
we're going to do
um
so I will write a just a summary of this
because it has to go in the calendar
explaining why we're okay with no
further regular um legislation and um
I think we're done thank you thank you
everybody especially thanks for all the
folks that put work in on this I really
appreciate it so often interim study is
uh
sometimes not taken seriously sort of a
soft kill but in this case it was
actually very valuable and I thank
everybody who made that happen so
and represent fellows I I would like to
second that you know as a retired state
employee and understanding the Staffing
shortages during covet I really
appreciate the the demand that we have
put on you and that you came and met
all right I think we're done